google vient de présenter son nouveau
smartphone c'est le pixel 7a on est sur
un smartphone Google avec un processeur
maison Google c'est la puce Google
tensor G2 qui est complètement optimisé
pour l'expérience Google avec je vous
montre par exemple la clarté des appels
si vous utilisez la carte des appels en
venant cocher cette petite case là votre
interlocuteur vous entendra vraiment
bien même dans un environnement très
bruyant ça viendra supprimer tout le
bruit extérieur il y a également la
gomme magique sur vos photos il y a la
traduction en temps réel la lecture de
vos SMS bref il y a énormément d'options
logicielles qu'on retrouve ici sur ce
pixel 7a et en plus de ça tous les trois
mois vous avez ce qu'ils appellent les
futurs drop les nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui sont poussées par
Google avec plein de nouveautés qui se
trouve ça juste génial bien que vous
ayez un double capteur derrière grand
angle et ultra grand angle il fait
vraiment bien le boulot parce que vous
avez derrière tout l'algorithme de
Google qui va venir optimiser la qualité
de vos photos Google nous a mis
uniquement un taux de rafraîchissement
qui va jusqu'à 90 Hertz 509 euros alors
ça reste quand même un certain budget
mais pour autant à tarif là vous avez
aujourd'hui un des meilleurs smartphones
de Google et ça c'est très cool donc si
vous intéresse je vous recommande ce
pixel 7a et d'ailleurs vous dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires